i wasn't sure if the white house knew
about the fbi raid on trump's residence
at mar-a-lago beforehand i wasn't sure
i'm not sure biden knows his name half
the time but i was not even sure that
the staffers at the white house who
really run the show over there knew
about the raid
until yesterday when white house press
secretary corrine jean-pierre said the
white house didn't know about the raid
which convinced me with 100 certainty
that the white house
definitely knew about the raid
can you tell us anything more was he
watching the news was he scrolling
twitter did someone in his staff flag it
for him i can tell you this he was not
uh aware of of of uh
of
of the uh was it the mar-a-lago raid i
don't know what you guys are calling it
uh before it happened uh hum and aham
and ahmanna i don't know i don't even
know what you guys are calling it uh um
a raid uh yes sorry never heard that
term before mara what now
donald who the fb huh
sorry not ringing any bells move along
move along next question
this woman is such a bad liar if she had
just said
yeah we didn't know about that yeah that
was all the fbi on its own
maybe i would have believed her
but to pretend not to have read about
the biggest news story in the country
which pertains to joe biden's
predecessor and chief rival in the next
presidential election
to pretend not to know what a raid is
karine jean-pierre was giving off
precisely the same vibes that hillary
clinton did in 2016 when she tried to
play dumb on wiping her email server of
classified material
under the law
that decision is made by the official i
was the official i made those decisions
what like with a cloth or something well
no
i i don't know how it works digitally at
all i do not have any
wipe the server
like with a cloth what's a server what's
wiping what's a cloth i don't i don't
know and she was obviously guilty as sin
the strategy didn't work because while
hillary clinton is many things she's not
dumb and joe biden is another story but
even biden and his lackeys are not
nearly as dumb as they play what we're
seeing right now is a systemic strategy
of persecuting the ruling party's
political opponents
we can say
with certainty that this is not going to
stop with trump and with the raid on
mar-a-lago
we can say that
because we already we already saw it
play out because less than 24 hours
after the mar-a-lago raid the fbi
confiscated the cell phone of a sitting
republican congressman i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from schmuttel who
says i work in archival work under a
former director of the national archives
i'm no expert but i know of nothing that
would prevent the president from taking
paper copies of archives to his summer
retreat even then it wouldn't take two
years for a raid to happen to get the
documents back the only paper copies we
would care about in the archives are
one-of-a-kind documents with no copies
unless trump has the declaration of
independence at mar-a-lago there's
nothing he has that the national
archives doesn't already have in
multiple forms that's a really great
point also worth pointing out that the
documents that trump has
what whether he has them or not that he
allegedly even has would be outdated
documents they would be several years
old at this point compare that to
hillary who had real-time classified
information on a server that was easily
hackable by foreign governments it's not
even comparable but of course there's no
raid on hillary's house and there is a
raid on trump at mar-a-lago why because
this isn't about national security this
isn't about some stupid federal records
act this is about stopping trump from
running for president again in 2024.
this is about joe biden and the ruling
liberal establishment killing its main
political opponents campaign in the
cradle if you ask me this sort of thing
undertaken by the president of the
united states at the very least
constitutes a very serious hr violation
okay and when you want to take care of
hr violations you got to check out bambi
right now go to bambi.com michael when
running a business you will get hit with
all kinds of crazy scenarios an employee
not showing up to work on time mandatory
sexual harassment or workplace safety
training wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations one complaint can destroy
your entire company problem is hr
managers are expensive they can easily
cost over 80 000 per year but with bambi
you get access to your own dedicated hr
manager starting at just 99
a month all of bambi's hr managers are
based in the united states and can
support the nuances across all 50 states
your manager is available by phone email
and real-time chat to help you
effortlessly run employee onboardings
and terminations encourage good
performance and make sure your business
stays compliant with ever-changing hr
rules with bambi's hr autopilot you can
automate the most important hr practices
such as setting policies training and
feedback in fact bambi clients are four
times less likely to have a complaint
filed against them go to bambi.com
michael right now for your free hr audit
you run your business let bambi run your
hr b-a-m-b-e-e dot com slash michael
bambi.com
michael with the fireworks around the
mar-a-lago raid people have missed the
story that took place right afterward
which in some ways is is
almost more significant
one day after the mar-a-lago array the
fbi confiscated the personal cell phone
of representative scott perry he's a
republican congressman from pennsylvania
that was while he was traveling on
tuesday with his family according to
representative perry this morning while
traveling with my family three fbi
agents visited me and seized my cell
phone they made no attempt to contact my
lawyer who would have made arrangements
for them to have my phone if that was
their wish i'm outraged though not
surprised that the fbi under the
direction of merrick garland's doj would
seize the phone of a sitting member of
congress this is approaching the level
of a constitutional crisis
i'm not sure that we're quite there yet
but if we're not we're pretty close
the
bureaucracy which is now under the
direction of christopher wray who's a
doj guy the doj is one of the executive
agencies under biden's control is now
going after republican members of
congress on what basis we don't really
know for sure but all of the reporting
we've seen is that this has to do with
donald trump's attempts to cast doubt on
the 2020 presidential election you know
the most secure election ever in human
history where they totally didn't change
all the rules beforehand and where they
totally counted the votes on time and
where they definitely didn't violate the
state constitutions and where they
didn't obviously rig the damn thing you
know that if you have any questions
about that if you cast any doubt
on the
election integrity
that we saw in 2020 why you're an
insurrectionist and the the feds have
the right to go in and what sees the
cell phones of sitting members of
congress
go in and raid the homes of the the home
of the former president and the
presumptive republican nominee in 2024
i i walk into work today one of my
colleagues greets me says hey how you
doing michael i say oh it's another fine
day in the banana republic we're
descending even further into a banana
republic
what is going on here i think
a lot of people
especially the squishes
are going to say oh well yeah this is a
little weird it's a little weird for
biden's fb highly politicized fbi highly
partisan fbi to go after the opposition
party members of congress and steal
their data and steal their cell phones
it's a little weird to be raiding the
homes of
the former president and the future the
presumptive nominee it's a little weird
but okay it's all right we'll get back
to normal it's totally fine no what we
are seeing play out in real time is a
major power grab and a shift in the way
that our political structure works
and that happens i don't think i'm being
conspiratorial here of course that
happens consider the way our government
looks today with the giant bureaucracy
and the the huge power that the federal
government has over the lives of
ordinary citizens and the
pretty much non-existent power that the
states have vis-a-vis the federal
government consider that and compare
that to the
the government we had in the 1790s
or the very early days of the 19th
century
or the late days of the 19th century or
the early 20th century it all looks very
very different
the way that the political order looks
changes over time and it changes with
power grabs and it changes with
audacious campaigns and it changes with
shenanigans and it changes with
illegality and it changes with rigging
elections and it changes with this
branch of government just seizing power
from some other branch of government and
this party just suppressing some other
political party and that stuff really
does happen last night i was sitting out
with a cigar and a drink and i was
reading
the constitution of athens i was going
back through some of my ancient greek
reading just to try to get out of the
the tumult and the chaos of the modern
news cycle and try to get a little bit
of a broader perspective and when you
just
read how the government of athens
changed over time
it's a comedy of errors it's a parade of
villains it's all sorts of things where
people come in and they say yeah that's
the way your government operated before
this is the way it operates now and you
might say that's unjust and you might
not like it well i don't give a damn
because i took the power
and it that didn't just happen in
ancient greece that happens in every
single state throughout human history
and it's happening here in the united
states
what we've seen play out over the last
two days is the fbi at the direction of
the doj which has been become highly
partisan and it's clearly at the
direction of the ruling party in the
white house they are saying hey
we're going to do some unprecedented
stuff
and we're going to do it you're going to
think it's unjust and you're going to
think it's breaking the norms and you're
going to think that it's a ruthless
power grab
tough
what are you gonna do about it and the
answer from the squishes
and the answer from people who are just
not
rising to the the call of this present
moment
is oh let's just let it play out nothing
to see here move along move along
senator tim scott who i like personally
he's a nice guy personally he just went
on cbs and he was asked about the raid
on mar-a-lago and he i think he gave the
single worst answer possible
there's been lots of questions before
this raid about whether or not the fbi
is doing their job apolitical and we
don't know the answer to that question
yet this is
about the fbi this is going to raise
more questions in my opinion we need to
let this play out and see exactly what
happens but we should all have been
stunned and surprised and shocked at
what happened yesterday the real
question is hey what is the federal
federal
records act and and b what are we
talking about it has to be something of
incredible magnitude yeah for at least
my side of the owl to say that was that
was warranted with without that i think
we're going to find ourselves in a
very big
mess as it relates to the credibility of
the fbi so you don't have any concern
that they're going to find anything at
the mar-a-lago well i think we should
really as opposed to rushing the
judgment the most important thing that
we can do is let it play out because i
have no idea what they were looking for
i don't think anybody knows
let it play out
let it play out
no we do not in fact need to let it play
out we do not need to worry about
rushing to judgment we're not rushing to
judgment
we've seen this play out for six years
now starting with the russian collusion
hoax we've seen the fbi and the doj
being wielded by the democrats
specifically against this guy against
donald trump to spy on his campaign to
try to stop him from becoming president
to try to oust him when he was president
now to try to stop him from running for
president again i've seen enough we're
not rushing to judgment this is six
years in the making and it's it's so
frustrating to hear tim scott say this
because the first part of his answer is
very good he says we're shocked this is
ridiculous this is terrible this is
awful
but let's not do anything about it
let's not do anything let's not even
let's not even
rush to conclusions let's just let's
just let the doj and the fbi and the
biden white house destroy donald trump's
presidential campaign and and wield
arbitrary capricious outrageous power
over their political opponents and
weaponize the federal law enforcement
agencies to to just go after and destroy
republicans and then you know once we
see how it plays out then maybe we can
think about doing something then maybe
we can think about fighting back are you
kidding me are you what a what a
worthless answer it's it's even worse
than saying it's not a big deal because
you're saying it is a big deal but we
shouldn't do anything about it come on
come on man come on i sound like joe
biden come on man
it's go oh it's got me i'm so i'm i'm
stress eating that's how frustrated i am
by what's going on and you know when i
stress eat i only eat the very best i
eat good ranchers good ranchers is my
absolute favorite meat delivery service
and they are on a mission to donate 100
000 meals to children in need to help
them out i am offering 10 lucky
listeners the chance to win 30 minutes
with me little old me via zoom
on september 30th where you can ask me
anything i hope that the topics are all
just steak and burger related but you
can ask me anything about anything else
you want to all you got to do is go to
goodranchers.com knowles buy a box of
meat using my code knowles can wles
you'll get 30 off your order plus free
shipping be automatically entered to win
an invitation to this exclusive
meet and greet
get it
meet and greet do you get it hurry hurry
up right now the offer is only valid
through august 31st goodranchers.com
knowles
meet and greet
tim scott
may have an ulterior motive
for not rushing to the defense of donald
trump which is that he is being floated
as a potential presidential nominee in
2024.
the the reason that this is coming out
right now is not just because of the
usual idol chatter about will he won't
he is this person gonna run is that
person gonna run it's because tim
scott's got a book coming out and the
publisher of the book
accidentally published this little blurb
here's the blurb from tim scott's
publisher senator scott is a rising star
who sees and understands the importance
of bipartisanship to move america
forward this book is a political memoir
that includes his core messages as he
prepares to make a presidential bid in
2022
so it's a little bit weird the copy here
obviously it wouldn't it would be 2024
unless he unless it means he's preparing
the bid in 2022 but he's going to run in
2024
but
that's coming from the publisher that's
not
that's not just coming from page six
okay that's not just coming from the
national enquirer
and if you look at tim scott's career it
does seem that he is positioning himself
such that he could run for president in
the future and i like him i like the guy
i've mentioned i've interviewed tim
scott i like him personally maybe he
could be a good presidential candidate
he ain't going to be a good presidential
candidate with this weak sauce that's
for sure
we just need to we just need to let
biden's doj run roughshod over all of
the republicans and destroy all of our
most popular leaders and then maybe we
can form some conclusions no i don't
think i've formed my conclusion i don't
know about you
i formed my conclusion frankly back in
2016 when it was so clear that the the
obama doj was spying on donald trump and
then it later came out that the fbi and
the doj were spying on trump
in collusion with the democrats it was a
total operation and there was no base
basis to the claims about russian
collusion
so i i formed my conclusion a long time
ago
and then you saw the ridiculous first
impeachment then you saw the ridiculous
second impeachment and then
now this
now this i've formed my enclave
republicans who haven't formed their
conclusion yet
you're not going to make it you're just
not going
to make it
will chamberlain who's a prominent
right-wing voice will tweeted out
yesterday something i think a lot of us
are thinking he said quote democrats are
behaving as though republicans won't
take power ever again
and a lot of people are looking at that
they're saying oh my gosh these guys
just they they're they're
behaving as though they are now the
permanently ensconced tyrants of the
united states now i think the
implication of this tweet is this is
very foolish for democrats to do because
republicans are going to take power
again and once republicans take power
those democrats are going to get
punished
but i don't think that's
the right conclusion
i think the tweet is right i think the
center it's true democrats are behaving
as though republicans won't take power
ever again but i think they're behaving
that way with good reason
because i'm not convinced republicans
are going to take any serious degree of
power anytime soon
that's not to say that republicans won't
win back the house i should hope in this
election year republicans will win back
the house not to say republicans won't
win back the senate it's a tougher
election map right now for republicans
so republicans may or may not win back
the senate it's sort of 55 45 60 40 but
maybe they will
republicans i guess kind of have the
supreme court
we just overruled roe v wade that's good
you got to count that as a win
but so what
let's say republicans even win the white
house in 2024 if the fbi and doj keep
acting this way i'm not not sure how
likely that is if the the libs keep
changing all the election rules to give
the democrats an advantage and to dis uh
disenfranchise republicans then i'm not
sure how likely that is but let's say
that even happens okay so then the
republicans have the house maybe the
senate maybe even the presidency and the
supreme court
you think that's the government
you think that's power in america
that's not that's not even close to a
majority of power in america
what are the other institutions that
wield power how about
the corporations
how about
big tech big tech oh my gosh big tech
controls the public square in a republic
the people who control speech
essentially control the political order
how about the education system
how about finance how about the banks
how about
all the rest of it
how about
how about the entire blob how about the
media how about the entertainment media
how about the news media about the
newspapers how about
everything
all of those other centers of power are
controlled by the libs
and they wield a lot of power and they
wield even more dangerous power than the
elected government because those other
forms of power are mostly unaccountable
and because they wield a lot of economic
power he who pays the piper calls the
tune
you're seeing proof of this right now
from nancy pelosi
nancy pelosi
just went on tv she went on nbc news
this was after her trip to taiwan which
many people thought created an
international incident because china
claims taiwan as its own the united
states traditionally has not
acknowledged taiwan as belonging really
to china
pelosi flies to taiwan as china's
threatening essentially to launch world
war three if pelosi goes to china
playing war games out all around taiwan
while she's there and then she goes on
tv
asked about the trip and she says what
are you talking about i don't think
taiwan's a real country
we still support the one china policy we
go there to acknowledge the status quo
is what our policy is there was nothing
disruptive about that
it was only about saying a china is
one of the freest societies in the world
don't take it from me that's from
freedom house let's talk a little
democracy courageous people and and it's
just i don't know why it is
except there's some commercial interests
who would like to diminish
the relationship
china is one of the freest societies in
the world
what
china is a flourishing democracy
what i guess you could sort of say that
about taiwan but but pelosi is saying
taiwan is part of china i
i hope she was just getting confused
here but i'm not sure that she was
because the democrats have been carrying
water for china for a very long time
pelosi says we support the one china
policy and this is very confusing
because the one china policy means
different things to different people
the one china policy is a policy created
by china which says we own taiwan
now in 1972 i believe it was the united
states also used this phrase we say we
acknowledge the one china policy but we
didn't acknowledge that taiwan belongs
to china we continue to support taiwan
in an ambiguous way do we support taiwan
independence well not exactly explicitly
do we support china's claims that it
owns taiwan no we certainly don't do
that so it's very unclear china says we
have the one one china policy america
says yeah yeah no we totally acknowledge
the one china policy but then we
we use that phrase to mean different
things
it gets even more confusing pretty much
every presidential administration has
held a different view on the one china
policy and sometimes there have been
different views even during the same
administration donald trump held the
view
basically that taiwan is a totally
separate entity at the first part of his
administration then by the second part
he kind of loosened up a little bit on
it and a seated more to china's claims
over taiwan now biden is much more
pro-china it's it's a complete mess
so why why the shifts and why is pelosi
not just
implicitly acknowledging china's claims
on taiwan but why is pelosi going so
much further to say china this communist
slave state that china is one of the
freest countries in the world
because he who pays the piper calls the
tune because the democrats in particular
are owned by china and because the
united states is in large part owned by
china china owns a trillion dollars of
our debt
china manufactures all our stuff
china holds a lot of natural resources
that we need increasingly that we're
going to need especially as we kill the
american energy industry
it's as as we commit american energy
suicide because of the democrats
environmentalist fantasies
then then we can't afford to oppose
china
he who pays the piper
calls the tune
speaking of money behind politicians
you know one of the the biggest funders
on the left is george soros george soros
is this crazy radical lib financier and
he's funded all sorts of terrible
left-wing candidates and right now in
particular he's funding prosecutors
all across america who don't prosecute
crime
so there are prosecutors who are
installed
at
dear cost to george soros who will let
the criminals off the hook and this is
leading to spikes and crime all over the
place one of those prosecutors in
particular is steve discano he's in
fairfax county in virginia
and steve discano is very very upset
because
a
an official in the yunkan administration
called him out for being on the payroll
of george soros
becky cleary says
well criticized soros funded prosecutors
what's your reaction to that
well i think that that is an unfortunate
way to frame this because when we are
trying to have a discussion about a
substantive matter especially about
crime like you and i are having right
now nick
for one party to go and immediately
get off topic and bring up george soros
is unfortunately a tried and true
anti-semitic trope that has been used in
this country
sin or a decade over decade after decade
when we're trying to talk about crime
and one part of that conversation
immediately goes
to a conspiracy about a shadowy cabal of
foreigners who are pulling strings
to destroy american culture
that is not a good faith argument it's
anti-semitic it's anti-semitic it's a
conspiracy theory george soros isn't
funding anybody he's not funding these
radical prosecutors like me except wait
a second i've got here
i've got here a column from the wall
street journal from about a week ago
says why i support reform prosecutors by
george soros
there he is no no that's an anti-semitic
hate fact pay no attention to the man
writing in the newspaper whose name is
actually george soros and it gets a lot
worse for this guy descano first though
for years we've been told that above all
else
we must to rest to the science
believe in the science which is me you
dirty rotten sheep
yet when it comes to presenting any
evidence to support the safety of
children taking experimental puberty
blockers to treat gender dysphoria
activist shrug what do they say they say
science we don't need no stinking
science just
shoot those kids full of those drugs the
only thing more appalling
than the left's hypocrisy is their
willingness to sacrifice children at the
altar of transgenderism no film does a
better job of exposing the danger
hypocrisy and lunacy of the trans cult
than matt walsh's what is a woman it's
already one of the most talked about
movies of the year its impact is
continuing to be
understood and spread help us keep the
momentum going by watching and sharing
what is a woman at what is a woman.com
that is what is a
woman.com head on over there today
george soros himself in a major
newspaper comes out and says i am
funding radical left-wing prosecutors
who are not enforcing the law who are
not prosecuting the criminals
and one of those prosecutors steve
discano gets called out by a younken
official named maggie cleary who
coincidentally actually is a friend of
mine going back to college i'm watching
this clip and it's this usual rigmarole
oh yeah it's anti-semitic it's fake it's
fake news it's a conspiracy move along
and he mentions maggie claire i said i
know maggie cleary she's great she's
terrific totally mainstream republican
great hire for glenn younkin and what
did she say she just said a fact
she said george soros is bankrolling
these guys and these guys are are
destroying law and order in our
communities all around the country and
they're leading to big spikes in crime
especially this guy steve discano he's
one of the worst
he's one of the worst of these liberal
prosecutors
and by the way
he's not just funded sort of indirectly
by george soros and because soros is
funding this movement and other people
are funding him this guy took at least
fifty thousand dollars directly from
george soros through the virginia
justice and public safety pack steve
discano took at least 50 grand it was
probably more than that
the justice and public safety packs are
the mechanism through which george soros
funds these prosecutors soros in the
last 10 years do how much he's spent on
just the prosecutors
just these da's just these these little
prosecutors this is just one tiny little
aspect of the whole political project
that taurus is engaged in
just here in the united states he spends
money around the world too
40 million dollars
40 million bucks on this kind of a thing
and what has happened
what has happened well you've got
another report here another new news
outlet national desk uh of this news
outlet says two dozen progressive
prosecutors linked to soros money you
saw a chase of boudin who just got
recalled up in san francisco led to all
sorts of chaos up there the la
prosecutor george gascon and a bunch of
others as well what what is this
that we are seeing
it's it's called the celebration
parallax that's the name that mike anton
who's the author of the flight 93 essay
he's at the claremont institute this is
this is the name that he gives to this
phenomenon
which is
the libs tell us that they are doing
something
and they're really happy about that and
they're celebrating that and then the
conservatives just repeat back to the
libs exactly what they have been
shouting and singing with glee
and then the libs
smear the conservatives as racists and
spreading fake news and conspiracy
theorists for saying the exact same
things the libs just said the libs get
to say it and it's true and wonderful
and worthy of celebration the
conservatives say exactly the same thing
it's a horrible conspiracy theory they
need to be
de-platformed it's anti-semitic
anti-semite as an anti-semitic to read
a fact about this one guy
that he admits in the newspaper it's not
as ann coulter told me when i was in
college when a liberal calls you a
racist you know you've won the argument
i think the liberals know that we've won
the argument they're not even having an
argument they're just saying you're not
allowed to say the same things that we
say
the the phrase celebration parallax is
kind of a it's a very fancy way of
saying it because a parallax is the the
position of the same object seen from
different angles so you're seeing it
from the liberal angle you're seeing it
from the conservative angle
but that that that is the way to
understand this and especially when you
look at the radon mar-a-lago there's no
raid on hillary clinton you see they're
going they're going after republican
congressmen for in any way associating
with donald trump and yet there's video
evidence of hunter biden hunter biden
committing all sorts of national
security endangering crimes they don't
do anything about that
it's a two-tiered system
it's a
it's a it's related to the celebration
parallax
the libs do the same thing that the
concert say the same thing well i'm
sorry i'm sorry i'm tongue-tied i'm so
frustrated by this
there's two sides to this the libs do
the same thing the conservatives do it's
good when the libs do it it's bad when
the conservatives do it
the libs say the same things that
conservatives say it's true when the
libs say it it's a crazy conspiracy when
the conservatives say you're seeing this
play out in new york right now eric
adams is the mayor of new york city eric
adams is very upset because the governor
of texas greg abbott is bussing illegal
aliens who are being encouraged to cross
the border by the democrats by joe biden
by the libs in new york and d.c and
elsewhere he's bussing them
to new york and dc and all the other
liberal cities
eric adams is furious about that he says
it's putting a severe strain on new
york's resources
it's horrific what what's going on
and eric adams says maybe he's going to
bust some new yorkers down to texas to
give governor abbott a piece of their
mind
i already called all of my friends in
texas
and told them
how to cast their vote and
i am deeply contemplating taking a bus
load of new yorkers uh to go to texas
and do some good old-fashioned
door-knocking uh because we
we have to for the good of america we
have to get him out of office
why you got to get him out of office
why what is abbott doing that is dr he's
sending illegal aliens to sanctuary
cities how's that for the good of
america it's a sanctuary city the
sanctuary city the whole premise is you
want the illegal aliens to come but you
don't you just want to say that it you
that you want the illegal aliens to come
you don't actually want them there
because you say that illegal aliens are
really really good for america and
they're net contributors and they don't
bring any crime and they don't bring any
social problems and yet the minute they
show up at your doorstep all of a sudden
this is horrific so horrific you're
going to load up a bus full of new
yorkers to go down there and beat up the
texans and get them to kick greg abbott
out of office
tells you everything that you need to
know speaking of new yorkers whining
you know that i am
really really obsessed with the kanye
west kim kardashian skeet davidson saga
i am i don't care i don't really follow
pop culture at all this story i'm really
really taken with
because i think it actually
cuts down to some of the core political
issues in america and also because kanye
west is very very funny and also because
skeet davidson is just not very likable
there's a
headline comes out of people magazine
skeet davidson is in trauma therapy
because of the taunts from kanye west
the attention and negativity coming from
kanye and his antics is a trigger for
davidson and he's had to seek out help
davidson has been in therapy
trauma therapy since april in large part
due to his beef with kanye west
i'm not surprised that pete davidson is
in therapy
pete davidson probably should be in
therapy he's had kind of a difficult
life his his dad
famously died in 911 sort of heroically
i think he was a new york firefighter he
goes in on 911 as a hero of that day and
so this is when skeet davidson's a kid
obviously that's a trauma and he's
engaged in all sorts of destructive
behaviors and now what because kanye
west makes fun of him on instagram
that's it that's what sends him over the
edge no i'm sure the guy's got a lot of
of issues but kanye west was absolutely
right
is absolutely right to taunt skeet
davidson
skeet davidson played a large role in
breaking up kanye west's marriage and
that's a no-no folks that's a no-no you
don't get to do that
marriage is sacred and the fundamental
building block of society and some
dirty looking
snl actor does not have the right to
come in and take your wife from you and
he also taunted kanye west he would send
him pictures apparently while lying in
bed with with kim kardashian and say oh
i'm in bed with your wife hahaha
no you don't get to do that
this this story the reason i'm obsessed
with it is it's a about a lot more than
kanye west and skeet davidson and kim
kardashian and yes i'm aware all of
these people have lived extremely
colorful eccentric in in many ways not
particularly virtuous lives but that's
even more to the point because while
they are
really wild crazy examples of hollywood
extreme and decadence in many ways
they're very human in many ways they're
representative of a lot of americans who
have kind of messy lives who have had
messy love lives and and
and
unclear and conflicting understandings
of how we ought to behave and they're
seeing that play out and all i know is
through these imperfect vessels you saw
kanye west at least
trying to
save his marriage at least saying that
he wanted to save his marriage
he was the representative of that and
this was after he had some kind of
conversion or reversion to christianity
and was very public about that this is
after he espoused some broadly
conservative political views and social
views
then kim kardashian go into a magazine
and say in my 40s i'm just going to live
for me and i'm just going to do whatever
i want it's about me me me which she's
the voice of a generation that's why
she's so popular and then you had skeet
davidson come in here and go and steal
another man's wife
so shameful so dishonorable
and you think among these three people
who am i going to pick i'm going to say
kanye
now some people will then come out on
this story and they'll say kanye has no
right
no right whatsoever
to
try to save his marriage or try to
attack the person who's helping to break
up his marriage what are you talking
about the people who say that are the
ones who think marriage doesn't mean
anything that marriage can be easily
dissolved at any given time that it's
just it's just a kind of contract you
can break the contract well it's a
contract except nothing about it is
binding so it's not even a contract it's
just two people kind of get along
together for a little and then whenever
you don't like each other as much
anymore you know he didn't do the dishes
last night and she's getting a little
older and so we're just going to split
it up and move on no no that might be
the lib view of marriage
that is not the conservative view of
marriage
and the libview says we're all
individuals who can do whatever the hell
we want whenever we want to do it the
conservatives say no the fundamental
political unit is the marriage and when
you make that vow
you're in it buddy you're stuck with it
this was the mainstream view in america
for a very very long time
now that's considered extreme people are
actually saying they're saying kanye's
gone too far here it is here's a
headline from metro kanye's gone too far
neither his genius or his mental health
or excuses why because he's defending
his marriage
kanye west
kanye west some years ago put on a big
giant foam suit and danced around to a
song singing you're such an effing hoe i
love it do you remember that
you're such a [ __ ] hoe
when the first time they asked you you
want sparkling or steal are you trying
to act like you drinking sparkling water
before you came out here
you're such a
i'm a sick guy like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick [ __ ] i like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick
[Music]
we had to blur out half of that song i
kind of forgot when i sent the clip that
we'd have to bleep out actually half of
the song that wasn't too far you're such
an effing hoe i love it i like to get my
well i can't even say it i'd have to
bleep out myself that's not too far
remember when kanye west went on t
national tv and he said that george bush
doesn't like black people
a lot of the people that could help are
at war right now fighting another way
and they they've given them permission
to go down and shoot us
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating is the lasting
damage to the survivor's will to rebuild
and remain in the area the destruction
of the spirit of the people of southern
louisiana and mississippi may end up
being the most tragic loss of all george
bush doesn't care about black people
please call
in the past few days
you remember that that that wasn't too
far that was genius that was all an
example of kanye's eccentric genius but
then kanye comes out and he says hey i
don't want to get divorced i think
marriage is a real thing and we should
stay together for the purpose of our for
the sake of our children and because we
took a vow and we should take this
marriage seriously and skeet davidson
should get the hell out of my bed
that's too far that's crazy
that hold you're defending marriage
you don't think that this sort of filthy
looking new yorker young guy should be
crawling around in your bed around your
house where your children sleep you
don't think that wow totally crazy there
was an article
in
i think it was the week or somewhere i
don't know occasionally i get google
alerts and they were going after me
because i said that we should defend
marriage and they said you know
republicans republicans are coming for
no fault divorce next to which i say
i hope so
yeah you're damn right we should i don't
know that we will because so many
republicans are so squishy and useless
but we certainly should go for no fault
divorce no fault divorce is insane
and it's a complete aberration in
american history new york did not have
no fault divorce on the books new york
one of the most liberal states in the
country did not have no fault divorce on
the books
until 2010. no fault divorce is a very
very modern invention
it really only began to be popularized
in the 1960s and 70s
before that
you had something known as wedlock you
had something known as marriage you went
out you took a vow before god
most importantly and before your spouse
and before the political community
and you said i'm going to stay in this
marriage
for ever till death do us part and if
you wanted a divorce divorce has existed
throughout all of human history but it
was hard it was discouraged all of the
political and social and legal incentive
was to remain married and work it out
and fix your marriage
and then in the 70s up really up until
just some a few years ago
there was this movement to say nah never
mind whatever we should all just get
divorced and be single and live for
ourselves and do whatever we want in the
minute the going gets tough we should
just cut and run and you know it's going
to screw over our kids and it's going to
traumatize a lot of people and it's
going to cause complete disorder in our
country because if you if effectively
abolish the the fundamental political
institution
you necessarily are causing a massive
amount of disorder but whatever
love is love the heart wants what the
heart wants whatever it's to you can't
make me do anything
choice choice choice individual autonomy
above all else
of course at
a conservative at the
bare minimum
must oppose
no false divorce
no fault people blame gay marriage
people blame the hookup culture people
blame all sorts of things for our social
uh disarray that we find ourselves in
and all those things have contributed to
it
no fault divorce might be
the biggest cause it's certainly up
there i mean no fault is a major issue
republicans are coming for no fault of
worse uh-huh
yeah i hope so or the republicans aren't
worth their salt
speaking of
going too far
andrew cuomo you remember him
the disgraced former governor of new
york big democrat he was being talked
about as a potential democrat
presidential candidate he was thrown out
ostensibly for a sex scandal but it
wasn't really for a sex scandal he was
thrown out because he he
lied about numbers during kovid he hid
covid deaths from the federal government
he was the absolutely the worst governor
in terms of how to actually handle the
health of the population during covid
and he was brought on cnn
constantly by his brother who was then a
cnn host talking about what a great job
he did so he got he got run out of time
but he's a big lib i mean he's got
liberal bona fides he came out
after the mar-a-lago raid he said doj
must immediately explain the reason for
its raid and it must be more than a
search for inconsequential archives or
it will be viewed as a political tactic
and undermine any future credible
investigation and legitimacy of january
6th investigations
yeah that's true they've gone too far
for andrew cuomo
joe biden who we were told he's the
moderate he's the reasonable one good
old uncle joe has gone too far
in the radical left power hungry
direction even for
andrew cuomo
i love how at the end he says this will
undermine the legitimacy of the january
6th investigations
yeah think that ship has sailed
when they wouldn't let any actual
republicans on the committee i'm pretty
sure that ship sailed when they let blm
off the hook for eight months for
burning down and raping and killing and
pillaging and burning they let those
guys off with a slap on the wrist at
most but then they throw the grandmother
you know who's standing around the
capitol rotunda they throw her in
solitary confinement yeah i think that
the legitimacy of the january 6th
proceedings and investigations that went
out the window but cuomo knows from an
optics perspective this is really not
great
this really does not look good for
democrats speaking of new york and going
too far this is a story i had meant to
get to last week i have to get to it
now
drag queen story hour begins in the in
the libraries
and the real conservatives object to
this and the squishes
go along with the liberals and they say
no i'll let it go into the libraries
don't worry it's not like it's in the
schools or anything what happens next
what happens next the drag queen story
hour goes into the schools
and the conservatives oppose it
they say we're slipping down the
slippery slope and then what happens the
libs and the squishes they say no it's
fine viewpoint neutrality everyone has
the right to do whatever they want
whatever they want to do it
at least it's not in the elementary
schools what happens next it goes to the
elementary schools and then what's the
final plan they say look
you might have moral opposition to drag
queen story hour and that's that's your
right
that's your right and so that's why you
know you've got your church for that you
don't have any right
to impose your own moral views on the
public in the public square
for some reason the libs have the right
to impose their moral views in the
public square but but you conservatives
you don't but you still have your
churches and guess what happened
you know it the drag queens have made it
to the churches her name is britta
filter and she is the queen of new york
there she is this is in a really
beautiful church in new york
forget
which one this is obviously a very
prominent
episcopalian church and there you this
is disgusting
this is so disgusting
a
dude dressed up as a chick
walking down the aisle
you're just waiting for lightning to
strike any second
and then these these clapping seals
in what was once
a church
getting up and clapping for this
degenerate show inside a church now this
initially was erroneously reported as
being a catholic church
which would be
a
an international scandal it's not it's
an episcopalian church and the
episcopalian church has ceased to have
anything even resembling a coherent
theology uh long long ago not sure that
it ever had one but it certainly doesn't
have one now i mean now they've got
priestesses and they do all sorts of
crazy things that have very little to do
with christianity if anything at all so
i'm not surprised but it's jarring to
see
because the church building it looks
like a church
right it looks like a church i bet the
men who built that episcopalian church
even though they were episcopalians
even which sometimes those guys were you
know a little a little squishy but i bet
they were
serious men who seriously wanted to
worship god and that's why they built
this big beautiful church
and now what has happened the libs have
crawled inside of it and just eaten it
out from within
and taken all the christianity out of it
and all the animating spirit out of it
and the essence out of it and filled it
up with a bunch of drag queens and
guffawing clapping seals
to cheer this on
if you
wed yourself
to the spirit of the age you will find
yourself a widow in the next great quote
we're not really sure who first said it
it was either fulton sheen or dean inge
but good good churchman
fulton sheen a catholic as a bishop
initially this was being reported as a
catholic high school here in new york
invited me to their pride chapel but no
it turns out it was an episcopalian
church that has a pride chapel
pride which goeth before destruction and
a haughty spirit before a fall
and i don't i don't even mean to to
be on my high horse here thank goodness
this wasn't a catholic church thank
goodness it wasn't a catholic church but
i bet there are a number of
communities that call themselves
catholic that would be fine with this or
something close to this and are only
being held
away from that by the magisterium and
the
weight of the catholic church
for now but i bet they they want to go
along with that spirit of the age
this will pass away
this will be seen as a scandal in the
not-too-distant future
the people who participated in this will
not be looked unkindly in history
and there will be a new spirit of the
age and the people who stick to the true
real things
the eternal things uh they they will
fare a lot better than these people
how did we get to this point we got to
this point because we abandoned all the
other defenses
because we we just left the little
individual churches on their own that's
not how society works that's not how
culture works
culture spreads threat you have a common
culture that's not how politics works
politics is in common it's in the public
it's how we all interact together
it this is this is the fruit of an
idiotic kind of individualist
sloganeering that we've had in recent
decades do you do whatever you want it
has no effect on me just that's fine you
want to have drag queen parades in your
school or your church or your that's
fine and we can't impose our views to
kick the drag queens out of the public
square
this is the fruit of that idiotic a
historical
incoherent kind of thinking no of course
it does this is bad
we have the right as a community to say
no to this we have the right to suppress
this we have the right to stop these
defying seals from bringing the drag
queens all around the public square and
frankly we have a responsibility to do
that
the way that power works is power tends
to flow to the people who are willing to
exercise the power
and this is why the liberals
are all there's much more to be said
about this but this is why the liberals
when whenever they create an image of a
conservative in popular culture they try
to do so in a kind of libertarian way
they think of ron swanson as the
greatest example in parks and rec he's
the conservative character he's really
kind of like a libertarian and the
reason they do this and the reason the
libs are always pushing this idea that
the the right is libertarian is because
it benefits the right the left
to have an opponent that doesn't want to
wield political power because they know
that if their opponents aren't going to
wield political power then they the libs
will have the opportunity to do that
it has led us to this place where now
you've seen a massive power grab so
massive that joe biden is raiding the
home of his predecessor and political
opponent are we going to wield political
power again no the squishes tell us wait
and see let it play out let's just see
how it goes we don't have the right we
don't want to jump to conclusions i've
reached my conclusions i should hope you
have to now that means it's time for us
to act i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022